So good. What the heck?
I never had a Caesar salad wrap.
I've been craving these so much
cause they're all over my for you page,
so I had to make myself one.
Let's get started.
This wrap was perfectly crunchy,
salty, spicy.
It was so good.
So I started by slicing up some sourdough bread,
drizzling it with some olive oil,
salt and pepper,
popping that in the oven to make my croutons.
While those were baking,
I made my breading for the chicken,
which was some egg,
bread crumbs and flour.
So then I drenched my chicken in the flour,
then the eggs and the bread crumbs.
I shallow fried my chicken
and basted it with the hot oil
to just get an even layer of brown crust all over.
Then I just let them rest on a wire rack
while I made my dressing,
which I just chopped up some garlic
and stuff some anchovies with that,
and then started on all the other components
for the dressing.
Gave that a really good mix
and added that to a bigger bowl
cause I realised my bowl was so tiny.
Kept whisking it,
adding oil until it looked creamy,
and then it was time to assemble the salad.
So I did romaine,
the chicken, croutons,
the dressing,
and obviously
can't forget about the Parmesan cheese.
I'm the worst at rolling up tortillas,
so just bear with me.
It doesn't look that great,
but it's absolutely amazing.
So good. What the heck